If you’re watching this on the day it comes
out, and you live in the US, we want to let
you know that it’s not too late to get some
Microcosmos products in time for the holidays!
At microcosmos.store we have expedited shipping
available on all of our products except the
Microcosmos Microscope, but to guarantee delivery
of your sticker pack or coffee mug by the
24th, you’ll have to place your order by
tomorrow December 20th!
So go to microcosmos.store now if you’re
still searching for that perfect gift for grandma!
Watching this Peranema feels a bit like watching
a cat waffling back and forth between whether
or not it wants to take a nap.
Sometimes the Peranema stretches, its body
undulating into an elongated, indescribable
geometry as its flagella twitch like whiskers.
And then, sometimes, it curls up into a cozy
circle, tucking one end into itself the way
any feline friend you might know curls up
around the perfect beam of sunshine.
When James, our master of microscopes, began
his journey with his first microscope, he
found Peranema in their elongated form.
But for some reason, whenever he went to record
them under higher magnification, the Peranema
reverted to their curled-up form, and James
did not know why.
He guessed—like many microscopists before
him—that this behavior had something to
do with the intensity of the light.
After all, switching to a higher magnification
on the microscope requires shining more light
on your sample.
And the more light that James shone on the
Peranema, the more he saw it curl up.
When we looked more into the bits and pieces
inside of Peranema, we were surprised to find
that it actually had something in common with
us, and with how we see the world.
It’s always thrilling to find something
in common with microbes, even if it shouldn’t
be surprising.
If you go back far enough in the evolutionary
history of human beings, you will hit upon
the ancestors we share with Peranema or other
present-day microbes.
And sometimes we have similar traits not because
we inherited them from the same ancestor,
but because nature itself is repetitive and
finds ways to make motifs out of chemicals.
And sometimes, evolution is a funny combination
of both of those things.
Take, for example, the family of organisms
that Peranema belongs to, the euglenoids,
a perennial favorite on Journey to the Microcosmos
because of the fascinating shapes they take
on, thanks to a series of strips made out
of protein that run the length of the organism.
If you are new to the world of euglenoids,
you may notice something starkly different
in some of these species.
Some of them are a very vivid green, which
makes them stand out like bright patches of
grass against an otherwise flat background.
And this sets them in distinct opposition
to colorless euglenoids like the Peranema,
which scrunch and wiggle and dance in the
same unusual way, but they are definitely
not green.
Now other than this very definitive color
difference, colorless euglenoids share a number
of traits in common with their green counterparts.
They use their flagella to glide and swim,
most use the constant shifting of their bodies
as a way to move around the microcosmos, a
motion called metaboly.
So why are some green and others are not?
Well the answer goes back to some ancient
euglenoid that developed its own photosynthetic
organelle, not by making it from scratch,
but by absorbing it from something else.
Most likely, it consumed some kind of green
algae millions of years ago, and then instead
of digesting its meal, absorbed the algae
and its chloroplasts into its own body until
they became one organism.
The process by which these green euglenoids
got their photosynthetic plastids is called
secondary endosymbiosis, an absorption of
an algae that had absorbed a cyanobacteria
like a nesting doll of photosynthesis, or
a poem that references itself as it unfolds.
And as far as motifs of the microcosmos go,
the recurrence of endosymbiosis is one of
the most dominant and consequential.
We have seen it over and over again as we
explore the evolution of
mitochondria and chloroplasts.
And it sets up a particularly important divide
among eukaryotes: those who can make their
own food, and those who cannot.
The green euglenoids with their photosynthetic
plastids are able to make their own food,
converting sunlight into the molecules that
sustain them and form the
basis for entire ecosystems.
But the Peranema, they’re like us.
They cannot make their own food, so they have
to hunt it down.
And they’re very good at it.
If an organism is small enough, the Peranema
will simply swallow it whole.
And if their prey is too large for that, the
Peranema will use a part of its mouth called
the rod-organ to cut up its meal into a more
digestible format.
And this need to gather or hunt our food is
not the only thing we have in common with Peranema.
As we said in the beginning, that unusual
curling behavior we saw happening has its
roots in something else we share with these
unusual microbes: rhodopsin.
For humans—and in fact for many animals—rhodopsin
is a protein that plays an important role
in our ability to see things, converting the
light that hits it into an electrical signal
that our brains can process into an image.
And rhodopsin proteins with similar sequences
have been found in all kinds of organisms,
including green algae and fungi.
And—it turns out—they are also found in
Peranema.
But the Peranema doesn’t see with its rhodopsin
receptors—at least not the way that we do.
Instead, when light hits the rhodopsin receptors,
it sets off an influx of calcium ions, which
in turns drives the organism to curl up into
a ball.
This behavior is similar to the way that bacteria
and archaea use rhodopsins to control their
tendency to reverse directions when they come
across light.
And the fact that this protein appears again
and again in different organisms makes it
a fascinating way to learn more about how
evolution has shaped and reshaped similar
components into different tools.
Because sure, something might be common.
But that doesn’t mean it can’t be fascinating.
Indeed, very often, it means the opposite.
Thank you for coming on this journey with us as
we explore the unseen world that surrounds us.
And thank you also to all of you who have
been doing your holiday shopping at microcosmos.store.
I’m very excited to know that so many people
are going to unwrap a microscopes this Christmas,
because getting to spend time with my microscope,
finding out what’s in my backyard, what's
in the little pond down the street, that's
been one of the best things about being a
part of this channel.
Now, at this point, most of you have probably
finished your shopping, and also, we are not
going to ship you a microscope in four days.
But for those of you who are hoping to pick
up some Microcosmos merch or some new plan
objectives for your loved ones, it is not
too late!
As long as you live in the US, and you can
pay for 2 day shipping it will arrive by the
24th, as long as you order by tomorrow, as
of this upload, December 20th!
So, if you’re still trying to figure out
what the heck to get your dad for christmas,
why not head on over to microcosmos.store, pick up
a new coffee mug, or some cozy Lacrymaria socks.
The people on your screen right now, they
are our Patreon patrons, and I want to say
thank you to them.
It has been another wonderful yeah of Journey
to the Microcosmos.
We've had a great time, we've learned lots
of things.
There's even been some legit science published
in peer reviewed journals.
If you'd like to be a part of what we do here
and help us continue sharing the wonders of
this marvelous microscopic world, you can
go to Patreon.com/JourneytoMicro.
If you want to see more from our master of
microscopes, James Weiss,
you can check out Jam & Germs on Instagram.
And if you want to see more from us, there
is always a subscribe button somewhere nearby.